welcome back to h20 special relativity
we want to continue our discussion of
galactic space travel
here the situation is slightly modified
from the previous one we still have at
least being our ground control and bob
riding on a spacecraft in order to
explore planetary systems and solar
systems
this situation is different in the sense
that
the spacecraft has an escape rod so it's
able to you know send probes to planets
in order to study there
and so in this specific case the
velocity
of this escape rod is uv
delta xb over delta pb as measured in
bob's reference plane the direction of
this velocity is the same as the
direct at the direction of bob's
spacecraft
we're looking in longitudinal direction
again as a reminder velocity is distance
over time or delta x over delta t so the
question now is what else are this
observed
this is an activity you should try to
work out yourself i stopped the video
i'll just continue here
so if you calculate now the velocity as
seen by alice
delta x a over delta t a that's given by
gamma times delta we just used lawrence
transformation gamma times delta xb plus
v times delta tb over gamma times delta
tb plus v over c squared delta xb
we can cancel the gammas and take out
delta tb out of the brackets
and then we find
u b plus v
over one plus v c square over c square u
v
so this looks like
an addition of velocities with a
correction factor one plus
v over c square u b
good so does this make sense so whenever
we have a calculation like this we
should check that
it it actually works out that extreme
cases are
preserved and that units work out so
again the units work out here on both
sides we find meter per second the unit
of velocity
if you check now what happens if you set
u b equal to zero meaning that
the escape rod is at rest with no
velocity with respect to bob's reference
frame
in that case we find that ua is equal to
v
exactly the velocity difference the
relative velocity between those two
reference strings
if that velocity is zero we find
ua equal to ub
again that's expected if bob and ellis
are in the same reference frame and they
observe the same escape rod they better
measure the same velocity
and lastly if you know instead of having
an escape rod we send the beam of light
out which has a speed
beam of light has a speed of light ub
equal to c
we find
that the velocity by observed by alice
is also c
which brings us to an interesting point
here
uh yes we still add velocities with a
little bit of a relativistic correction
but we will never get larger velocities
of the speed of light so the speed of
light
is a
absolute speed limit
let's analyze this a little bit more
in the context of our light clocks
so what now happens if the velocity is
equal to c is that gamma goes to
infinite
and
in the in the context of the light clock
you can notice that you know the upper
mirror
is can never be reached it's moving with
the speed of light the same velocity as
the light itself but light is never able
to reach this the clock will stop
all right so there's an absolute limit
of velocity is the speed of light
okay so now so far we discussed only
velocities in the direction in which the
two
reference frame uh move or the second
reference that moves respect to the
first one
what now happens if
we consider perpendicular velocities so
in this case
bob spacecraft
um this escape rod goes up
you know maybe it's just you know you're
circling the planet or you're just
approaching the planet and you've got
first one gonna pop that that planet
specifically
so here we want to work out the example
in which the perpendicular velocity is
not zero but the longitudinal velocity
is zero
so what does
alice observe so we do this as a concept
question which of the four answers is
correct
is the velocity unchanged because we are
studying perpendicular velocity
uh is the velocity smaller larger or you
don't know because we actually have to
figure it out work it out
okay so the velocity as observed by
alice is actually the absolute value is
smaller than the one observed by
by bob we can do the very same
calculation so we have
u b
y
is delta y b over delta t b
and then for alice this is u a y delta y
a over delta t b
so the y component the length measured
in y direction between bob
and others is invariant as we saw in the
previous section but the time is not so
we do have to
do the learned transformation of delta
ta
and find that in the case where the u b
x is equal to zero that we just have to
divide u b
y over gamma
situation is a little bit more involved
and there's also a longitudinal velocity
but you see here how this would unfold
so 2 was the correct answer here so
while the length in longitudinal
directions are invariant
the velocities are not and that's
because
time suspect time needs to be corrected
and the two reference things